where do you want to take all the smoke
because you guys have done so much in
such a little amount of time I feel like
you guys have really
put a stake as just the premier
basketball podcast uh um you know I
think you guys do it in my opinion you
guys are the best appreciate that man
thank you
um first and foremost continue to
inspire you know I mean I want people to
know that like we could tell our own
stories now you know similar to what
you're doing and how you inspiring
people in your space like other people
have always told our stories and now the
fact that we can tell our stories and
articulate you know how we really feel
and what's going on instead of having to
hear from someone else you can hear from
us
so first and foremost we want to
continue to do that but then just you
know create great content you know I
think that you know the the secret to
our our success is like that's really my
brother I mean so like we can talk real
[ __ ] to each other and say [ __ ] to each
other that other people can't you know I
mean so we always keep it light and and
always joking on each other you know
when you come to all the smoke you know
when you get there we're most likely
smoking listening to music eating good
food taking shots you know I mean like
Kickbacks so we wanted just to create a
really cool environment when you come
[ __ ] with us
um that you just feel comfortable enough
to kind of let your guard down you know
what I mean so I think that's what we've
been able to create with all the smoke
or you know the people say all the time
like man I've never told nobody this and
you're like damn they feel comfortable
enough it kind of reminds me of like the
athlete version of like drink Champs
because people go in there like yo
Noriega is our guy we've known him for
20 years everyone's having fun like you
kind of let your guard down because
you're in a trusted yeah environment you
know you know you know they know we're
not trying to do we don't want to go
viral for the wrong reason you know I
mean like my whole goal is all which is
to humanize our guests like we know why
Steph and KD and Kobe were great and
Shannon sharp and Snoop were great like
what are they like doing other [ __ ] how
do they become who they became so I
always just want to show people the
other side of you know some of your
favorite people and um you know we've
you know we we found lightning in a
bottle with this with this show you know
so I just you know I just think the
evolution I just we just started season
four and I told our team like you know
we got to continue to elevate so we just
did our we did a live show in December
with Magic Johnson
um at um the Beverly Hills and shout out
to Beverly Hills so we did a live show
with a live audience so that'll be
dropping I think next week which is dope
but I just think
um live shows
um being on linear television as well as
YouTube getting on that real Showtime
platform and and and and really kind of
continuing to just
spread our wings man it's been fun like
you know Showtime a big shout out to
show time and malcooks who's kind of
their in-house production they just
allow me to create a lot of other and do
a lot of other things outside of doing
all the smoke you know they've allowed
me to bring talent in creating shows uh
producing shows like I'm doing a bunch
of different things about that umbrella
so I think it's obviously very
beneficial for both of us so it's been
fun yeah do you feel like uh because you
have you have a documentary coming out
about your life right no so we did it
was just a short
um a thing called Revolution that just
dropped on Apple Amazon all those kind
of things it was just kind of a snippet
of you know life after basketball and
what I was kind of doing at the time I
was bored right when I retired because I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
next so we kind of just started filming
my activism and
uh you know my street activism you know
my cannabis activism fatherhood like
just what life was like as I was
transitioning
um from the NBA so should we started
shooting like five years ago we kind of
just wrapped a bow on it and and put it
out so it was just a kind of a snippet
of what's going on in my life